he spent weeks fighting to keep his
campaign alive but on Saturday former
Vice President Joe Biden was back in the
race a few months ago victory in South
Carolina was a foregone conclusion that
both Bernie Sanders and billionaire Tom
Styer made inroads at threaten Biden's
bid for the Democratic ticket now though
Joe Biden's campaign is alive and
kicking thanks to all of you the
Democratic we just wanted we've won big
because of the Biden's victory ends
Bernie Sanders winning streak after he
emerged as the front-runner in the first
three contests the senator from Vermont
finished second and is now looking to
Super Tuesday when 14 states in American
Samoa hold their primaries
they'll account for a third of all
delegates a potentially game-changing
day in US politics tonight we did not
win in South Carolina
and that will not be the only defeat
there are a lot of states in this
country nobody wins them all Joe Biden
downplayed his early losses instead
focusing on more diverse states his
campaign received a crucial endorsement
when congressman james Clyburn the most
powerful democratic politician in south
carolina endorsed him just three days
before the vote that seal of approval
may have pushed undecided
african-american voters a crucial voting
bloc here to back Biden so get up take
back our country this is the United
States of America there's nothing beyond
our capacity if we do it together
Elizabeth Warren and Pete butter George
trail the pack with disappointing
results Joe Biden's referred to South
Carolina and its large population of
black Democratic voters as his firewall
and it's held steadfast for a campaign
now renewed to say this was a boost for
Joe Biden's campaign would be an
understatement
the first diverse state in the
Democratic primaries has given the
former vice president the kind of
legitimacy and momentum he needs many
establishment figures in the Democratic
Party have been looking for a moderate
to take on Bernie Sanders now they may
have found him
Anna Gallagher al Jazeera Columbia South
Carolina